charlie barnes
in just his seventh major league
appearance it'll be start number six for
the former clemson tiger trying to get
out of this sitting with no damage done
so instead of two two counts and the
pitch is swinging a line drive to center
field buxton drifting near the warning
track and left center makes the catch
and that's the inning cleveland doesn't
score leaves a man lineup for minnesota
we'll go up against logan allen who has
made 10 starts already this season he
has been hurt by minnesota in two starts
this year
maybe just means he's due next time they
face him
there's the fastball to come back and
get buxton and there's one away just gas
right here after all the breaking balls
he goes up the ladder on buxton nice
sequence by logan allen now the 2-2
pitch check swing did he go yes on the
appeal at first john lipka ring them up
strikeout number two and sometimes
pitchers can forget that that guy behind
the plate is working with them not
against them and trust
todo just won for his last 15.
the pitch to him a curveball bangs on
the ground a third change to second
there's one miller gets rid of it in an
ending double play and another really
good encouraging sign from logan allen
barnes delivers the lefties pitch swung
on banged up the middle by the diving
shortstop simmons into left center the
indians have their first hit here's
ahmed rosario with a runner at second
third inning no score in the pitch swung
on drill deep right center field this
one is headed for the wall bangs off the
scoreboard high on the 23-foot wall in
the scores mercado and an rbi double to
right center by ahmad rosario and when
ahmed rosario has been so hot it's been
because he takes the ball the other way
and he hammered one about halfway up the
23 foot wall in right center got to
locate up which we talked about he's
been successful with so there's a lot
that goes into it
another payoff pitch and ramirez pulls
it down the left-field line towards the
corner and fair
two-nothing cleveland jose ramirez
cruises in it's back-to-back rbi doubles
for rosario and ramirez oh two outs
again why do you pitch to jose ramirez
he gets a change-up up 3-2 see that's
where we talked about the young guy you
got to know what you have there right
first base open rookie catcher rookie
pitcher why let the best hitter for the
cleveland indians beat you with two
hours out to center here in his first
at-bat he takes a change up and he lines
one to left it's going to get down for a
base hit here comes ramirez gordon's
throw to the plate cut off near the
third base foul line and it's
three-nothing indians
another change up by barnes not a
terrible pitch
fran mel reyes is a large human
he gets it off the end of the bat and
just muscles that ball great job by jose
ramirez running the bases scores easily
here's anderton simmons you're not
playing a different game in september
that you were in july or august on the
ground towards third good pick by chang
to flip the second trying to turn
stretch by bradley beautiful double play
simmons hits his ball hard
chang with a little bit of a bobble but
what a turn at second base right there
by miller
simmons instance he thinks all right i
got a chance and then chang knocks it
down
perfect feed to miller and then a quick
turn for the double play to erase that
leadoff hit from the twins
so here's jeffers who singled the center
in the second
polanco can take off
rope to the left field and down the line
it's a fair ball into the corner to
score a pair
jeffers connects with his second hit and
he cuts the lead down to one with a two
run double jeffers has been paying
attention to the game he's been noticing
logan allen's been throwing a lot of
curveballs he gets one up right there
rips it down the left field line
put the twins on the board make it a
three to two game
nice swing that's still a pretty cool
moment regardless
2-2-2 hasta dio is lifted in the air
deep right field ranging back reyes and
it's over his head to tie the game
beginning for the twins and la tortuga
has made it 3-3
we mentioned assadio put the ball in
play shortens up when he hit this the
way he reacted he reacted like he was
over his head
i thought it was a routine fly ball
friend mel reyes has been a dh most of
the season gets over his head for
the tying double for pasta dio and the
twins this is the lone lefty in the
lineup and nick gordon
goes after the first pitch and he's
gonna give minnesota the lead
a four run fourth inning and the twins
have come right back to jump out in
front well out of nowhere the twins
had struggled with runners in scoring
position gordon gets a slider not a bad
pitch again this is twice now he's
gotten balls down out over the play from
logan allen
smoke
smokes that one up the middle
to give the twins a 4-3 lead
lds kyle bearclaw on for the fifth time
in a twins uniform
2-2 to mercado and he goes down swinging
bear claw gets him with the breaking
ball
this is a nasty nasty breaking ball here
by bear claw just watch the bottom fall
out of this you see the spin
here's the payoff pitch swung on a miss
got him on a fastball 94 on the cheese
for stefan one away for ref schneider
3-2 and ref schneider hits it hard down
the line and shoots it into the corner
of bear ball
gunning for two and he'll cruise in with
a stand-up one-out double here in the
bottom of the six the twins looking for
some insurance
that's a nice piece of hitting by ref
snyder he gets a nasty slider this is a
pretty good pitch it's in the middle of
the play but you see how he's fooled
by the speed
he just gets the barrel out places this
ball down the left field line for a one
out double for the twins so he's aboard
in scoring position for jeffers
he's had a good day at the plate
goes after the first pitch sends one a
deep center field half a day ryan
jeffers right on target
two run shot insurance for the twins
this is an absolute
blast
by jeffers hits that pitch fastball he
knows it right away just barrels it back
legs whatever you want to say
sticks his tongue out and the best part
watch the guy in the outfit with the
target
hit the target out there
i don't know what the replay is for the
ball is in the flower beds
just going to make stefan sit out there
look at the replays
the home runs the review let's see
i mean hopefully they're not looking at
like fan interference interference maybe
yeah that ball's way out and now he's
mad he spiked his
and now it's alex coleman 13 of 20 in
same chances a lot of blown saves but
most of the bullpen has been much better
as of late
straw bounces it to the left side
ostadio on the run straw slides not in
time he's out
and that's the ball game
hasta dio with some strong defense over
the course of this evening cola may
comes on for the save and a 6-3 twins
win to
even up this double-header